si maurice papon se porte partie civile
c'est pour cet article paru dans le
monde du 20 mai dernier l'historien jean
luc einaudi il met en cause la
responsabilité directe dans la
répression sanglante de la manifestation
d'algériens du 17 octobre 1961 préfet de
police à l'époque des faits maurice
papon attaque l'historien pour
complicité de diffamation envers un
fonctionnaire public
il réclame un million de francs de
dommages intérêts cette plainte n'est en
aucune manière une manoeuvre c'est
simplement le droit légitime car maurice
papon de faire cesser la pseudo
historien et de faire taire un pseudo
historien qu'il le dit femme depuis 15
ans jean luc et nous dit et pourtant
l'auteur d'un ouvrage de référence sur
les événements d'octobre 1961 il a
également témoigné sur cette affaire
dans le cadre du procès papon devant la
justice il contenir défendre son travail
d'historien puisque maurice papon dhr le
poursuivre en justice
eh bien je vais répondre évidemment je
vais faire citer des témoins et il sera
établi qu'il ya eu un massacre commis
sous la responsabilité de maurice papon
en attendant jean-luc et no 10 a reçu le
soutien du mrap
une pétition en sa faveur a déjà
recueilli la signature de 200
personnalités le procès juillet
le 4 février 1999 un procès qui aura au
moins le mérite de relancer le débat sur
les responsabilités exactes du massacre
du 17 octobre 1961